I'm a crunchy mom, of course.
I use non toxic laundry detergent.
If you come to my house,
you're gonna see me breastfeeding 24 7.
I'm a crunchy mom, of course.
We spent our whole day outside
and walk barefoot outside.
I'm a crunchy mom, of course.
Our medicine cabinet is full of herbal tinctures
and natural remedies.
Crunchy mom, of course.
I add minerals to our water.
I'm a crunchy mom, of course.
I cooked a majority of our foods from scratch because I
cannot trust a single package in the grocery store.
I'm a crunchy mom, of course.
I own all crunchy books.
We all use magnesium before bed.
I'm a crunchy mom, of course.
We all use non toxic toothpaste in our house
without fluoride in it.